il ne faut jamais dire jamais l'adage
est d'autant plus de circonstance que
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire le
gouvernement a dit tout à fait tout et
son contraire masque pas sanitaire
obligation vaccinale pour certaines
professions tout ceci a fini par être
exigé alors un confinement des français
non vaccinés à l'image de ce qui se
passe en autriche c'est l'un des
scénarios qu envisage sérieusement
certains candidats à l'investiture des
républicains s'y lie à une recrudescence
de la pandémie qui mettent en danger des
vies je ne confierai pas tous les
français les français qui se sont fait
vacciner ont pris leurs responsabilités
j'envisagerai leur confinement
uniquement des non vaccinés s'il ya des
décisions difficiles à prendre je les
prendrai à l'égard des non vaccinés
l'exécutif de son côté se montre moins
catégorique
pourquoi d'abord parce que depuis
juillet une partie de la population se
mobilise déjà chaque samedi contre le
pas salutaire en pause et un confinement
aussi millions de français non vaccinés
ne ferait que mettre de l'huile sur le
feu et à cinq mois de l'élection
présidentielle
ce n'est pas forcément bon calcul nous
ne le souhaitons pas et nous devons tout
faire pour empêcher que nous ayons
besoin d'aggraver les moyens de
protection des français l'objectif est
la méthode que nous avons tenu c'est
celle de la vaccination et du rappel la
france n'est pas à l'abri d'une nouvelle
vague alors que la france compte plus de
51 millions de primo vacciner comme vous
pouvez le voir derrière moi gabriela
talent le porte parole du gouvernement
continue d'appeler les français à se
faire vacciner et revacciner la
cinquième vague sera celle des non
vaccinés et des personnes fragiles non
rappeler chaque injection éloigner un
patient de l'hôpital et nous rapproche
collectivement d'un hiver serein d'un
point de vue juridique l'exécutif
peut-il décrété un confinement pour les
seules personnes non vaccinées pas
vraiment l'état de droit ne le permet
pas d'autant que cette possibilité ne
figure pas dans les termes
l'état d'urgence sanitaire sous lequel
le pays ce n'est même plus placé
actuellement il a en effet été remplacée
par une période transitoire de sortie de
l'état d'urgence je ne pense pas que
l'on puisse prendre des mesures
différenciés en fonction du statut
vaccinal car la seule différenciation
que permet l'état d'urgence sanitaire et
territoriales il ya une vraie question
démocratique et de cohésion sociale avec
ce type de mesure augmenter les
contraintes sur la population qui
refusent le vaccin serait susceptible de
la radicaliser sans pour autant parvenir
à la faire changer d'avis d'un point de
vue constitutionnel il semble difficile
d'imposer des contraintes aux seuls non
vaccinés le conseil constitutionnel
pourrait en effet retoqué cette décision
sur la base d'une rupture d'égalité des
citoyens devant la loi l'article 6 de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen de 1789 stipule que la loi doit
être la même pour tous et ce qu'elles
protègent ou bien qu'elle punisse
déclaration sur laquelle s'est assis
malgré tout plus d'une fois le
gouvernement ces dernières années
notamment en interdisant plusieurs
manifestations de gilet jaune